hello grammarians in this video I'm
going to tell you about a piece of
punctuation called the colon the colon
is these two little dots right here one
stacked on top of the other and it has
quite a few functions just like a lot of
other pieces of punctuation the idea of
this linking function is that the colon
can link an independent or dependent
clause with another independent or
dependent clause or a phrase or a word
when there's a strong connection between
the two things that it's linking so if I
want to tell someone what I think about
two movies about animals I could say
both movies are great but sky pal has
one thing that makes it better
dogs that play sports this is one
sentence with two parts that are linked
with this colon so the first part says
both movies are great but sky pal has
one thing that makes it better and that
could stand alone as a sentence but it
doesn't tell us what that one thing is
so the colon comes in and tells us I'm
about to tell you what that thing is
dogs the play sports so in this case the
colon just sort of serves as a
connection between the purple part of
the sentence and the yellow part of the
sentence
another example is something like going
skydiving made me face one of my
greatest fears parachutes right again
this colon is sort of linking these two
parts of the sentence where one answers
an unanswered question from the first
part like what is this greatest fear
well it's parachutes the colon is here
to link between this whole independent
clause and the word parachutes I could
just as well say going skydiving made me
face one of my greatest fears period
that's a perfectly fine sentence but
without a colon linking to what that
fear is that sentence kind of just
leaves us wondering so another sort of
subset of the colons ability to link
things is that it can introduce things
one thing that the colon can introduce
is a list I could say we needed to find
three more items on the scavenger hunt a
four-leaf clover a cauldron and an
abandoned ship the second thing a colon
can introduce is an item if I'm talking
about the other day when I had a weird
legume craving I could say I only wanted
one thing from the grocery store peanuts
lastly a : can introduce a quote so my
friend Liz says it best never open a jar
of pickles you can't close I'm not
really sure what that means but she does
say it best so as you can see like it
was in the first couple example
sentences there's kind of information
missing from the first parts of all
three of these sentences we needed to
find three more items on the scavenger
hunt
well what did you need to find or I only
wanted one thing from the grocery store
what did you want or my friend Liz says
it best well what does she say that's
where the colon comes in to introduce
that missing information so there's one
final case of the linking function of
the colon that I want to get into in
this video if you remember from the
beginning of the video I said that
colons can introduce an independent
clause to another independent clause
sometimes that's pretty rare usually
that's the job of a comma and a
conjunction or maybe a semicolon but as
always it's still important for you to
know even the things that don't happen
all that often
something like remember to take off your
sunglasses when you drive through a
tunnel you can't see when it's that dark
the colon in this example shows that you
can't see when it's that dark is an
explanation of why you need to take off
your sunglasses this is one of the two
types of sentences where it makes sense
to have a colon between two parts of the
sentence that could stand on their own
as individual sentences so we can say
one the second part explains the first
part the other case is when the second
part of the sentence is emphasized so
this would be something like I drank way
too much soda I'm never going to fall
asleep these are two independent clauses
that could be their own sentences but
they're closely related enough that it
makes sense to have them connected as
one so the colon links them together and
the second part is emphasized right
that's the focus of the sentence I'm
never going to fall asleep so in these
two sentences we can see that the colon
can connect to parts that can stand
alone as their own sentences right
whether it's two independent clauses
like in the second sentence or an
independent clause that's technically
connected to a dependent clause but can
stand alone now okay this usage a
is really uncommon I really want to
stress that usually when we're uniting
two independent clauses or at least two
parts of a sentence that can stand on
their own as individual sentences we're
going to use a comma and a conjunction
or a semicolon but in the case that the
second clause or the second part of the
sentence is emphasized or explaining the
first clause then you'll want to use a
colon just keep that in mind usually
this independent to independent clause
linking happens with the semicolon and
not a colon but regardless this is
important to know it's possible in these
specific cases what's most important for
you to take away is that the colon can
link things and introduce things as part
of its many functions and that's the
linking function of the colon we've got
independent clauses dependent clauses
phrases words and introductions for
lists and items and quotes you can learn
anything
page out